a sea of solidarity lighting up central
budapest
thousands of hungarians standing up for
press freedom
which many fear is disappearing under
the rule of right-wing prime minister
viktor orban
the latest victim hungary's most red
news site index.hu
seen as one of the country's last
independent media
that's made it a frequent target of the
prime minister who once called it a fake
news factory
but its independence has come under
threat after an orban
ally bought control of the site's ad
sales
the final straw came a few days ago when
the site's editor-in-chief was fired
prompting more than 80 staff to resign
on friday
our editor-in-chief was fired this week
and while i don't want to speak on
behalf of all of us
for me this was the red line i cannot
work there anymore
shortly after thousands of protesters
flooded the streets
we want information real news and it's
getting more and more difficult
almost impossible to get that in hungary
now
we don't know what's happening around us
because the state media
isn't telling the truth
honestly regardless of the website the
reason why i came to demonstrate
is that another independent news portal
has fallen victim to the government
i really don't like that and that's why
i came i don't think there's any free
press left
hungary's foreign secretary denies the
government poses a threat to press
freedom
show me a concrete case when was a
journalist in hungary not allowed to
write what they thought
index is just the latest of several
hungarian news outlets to fall under
control of government allies raising
fears here
that it won't be the last
for more on this i'm joined by
journalist justin spike in budapest
justin thousands of people taking to the
streets to show their
support for the press more than 80
journalists from index walked out
are we seeing a tipping point in hungary
uh thank you for having me uh so
what's happening now with index is
particularly significant because as you
mentioned
index was the biggest and the most
popular independent uh
news outlet in the country the firing of
its editor-in-chief
uh was really the red line for many of
these journalists because
it represented such a major force in
bringing credible and objective
information to the people of hungary
in an environment where the media is
being continually
shrank in the country via purchases by
by government-friendly business people
and
these kinds of interventions so the
protest that we saw i think shows
that uh there is still a lot of support
and a lot of hunger for
credible and independent uh news
reportage
in hungary um but i think it surprised a
lot of people that
index was moved upon in such a quick
manner it surprised me as well
what does this do to the media landscape
in hungary
how independent is the media there now
so as the foreign minister mentioned in
your previous clip
uh journalists can write what they want
there's not a
there's not censorship of the internet
uh
but but the environment is being
continually
whittled away um so what happened to
index recently is almost a carbon copy
of what happened to the previously
largest and most popular
news website which was called origo the
same thing happened in 2014
businessmen close to the government uh
got close to that website in fact the
same businessman
uh who who bought himself into index
just earlier this year
and then the editor-in-chief was fired
and then there were mass walkouts
so there are still a number of
independent outlets
available in hungary i happen to be a
contributor to one of them
they're mostly all on the internet but
uh the point is that uh
the it's it's highly unbalanced um a
couple of years ago there was a
foundation
which uh which was created which
subsumed basically
around 500 um different media outlets
and print
news uh newspapers radio etc
all across different mediums and uh and
that is
a foundation which is controlled
directly by the government and it's been
labeled a
uh a matter of national interest
so you have this handful of independent
sites
uh on one hand but then you have this
massive uh
empire essentially of
government-controlled media on the other
yeah certainly a deterioration justin
spike in buddha
budapest thanks very much
you